[Music]
now why is President Trump suddenly
worried about saving jobs in China Trump
may ease off a u.s. ban on exports to
Chinese telecom maker in big giant ZTE
tweeting too many jobs in China lost
however the heads of the FBI and CIA
have warned Americans against buying ZTE
phones because they're considered
national security risks Senator Marco
Rubio says it's crazy to help ZTE
I spoke with him just a short time ago
senator Rubio you have been writing and
speaking a lot about the China threat
over the last several months and this
really took me by a complete surprise
today with this seeming reversal of what
I thought was a very common-sense
approach to the Chinese telecom giant
what is your reaction tonight the White
House seemed to try to back off a little
bit in reaction today China will have to
make concessions on its past cheating
frankly but what is your reaction as of
why yeah first of all I don't feel bad
for these companies because frankly
they've benefited greatly and continue
to benefit greatly from the theft of
intellectual property and cheating which
is what the Chinese government does on
behalf of their companies what's really
concerning as telecommunications is one
of the ten or twelve industries that
China intends to dominate the world in
and so to be selling American technology
to ZTE is going to allow them to get it
and then reverse-engineer it and then
they'll make it themselves and they
won't need us anymore they do that in
every industry but remember this this
enforcement action against ZTE was not a
trade issue it was because they got
caught helping North Korea and helping
Iran evade sanctions and they were
punished for it but frankly we should
not be in the business z:t should not be
operating unfettered in the United
States and they shouldn't have access to
American technology yeah senator Rubio
you there's always this tension between
the national security side of things and
the economic side of things and it seems
that the Trump is trying to triangulate
on this obviously there's concern about
our farmers and the soybean tariffs that
China is threatened to put on them also
with the upcoming talks with North Korea
without a doubt China's played some role
in facilitating perhaps
we've gotten to this point this far do
you take that into consideration as you
judge this no because without national
security you have no economy and in the
case of China part of our national
security threat is that they intend to
wipe out United States industries and
ten key sectors it's called made in
China 2025
they've telegraphed a very character Lee
they intend to dominate the world in
these ten industries and one of the ways
they do it is they take American secrets
they either spy on us and steal them or
they get American companies to do
business with them and then they take
whatever it is we invented and they
learn how to make it themselves you know
even though they're not allowed to under
the law and then they get rid of us and
then they start competing with us
subsidized by their government you do
that in enough sin industries and it
becomes a national security threat and
then in the case of ZTE and
telecommunications these are devices
that could be theoretically used not
theoretically they can be used to track
people to listen and without any court
orders or anything of that nature it's
just if this was a farm dispute that's
one thing but this is a direct threat to
our national security and our economic
well-being which are interrelated
Marco Chuck Schumer today said and I've
known you for so long so I just called
you Marco excuse me Chuck Schumer
tweeted out kind of an agreement with
you and myself but he was pretty hard
she said make China great again you
don't believe that Donald Trump wants to
is interested in making China great
again or would purposely harm our
national security interests by doing
some type of deal with China on this do
you know I think I don't I just think
there's a lot of people chirping over
there you know every day some group of
CEOs comes marching in to the White
House and tries to talk the president
down from the strong stand that he's
taken on China there's a lot of voices
perhaps even some people within the
administration that want to back down a
little bit on the China thing looked at
this confrontation with China is by far
the most important thing facing this
country on a global scale this is going
to define the next 30 years the next 80
years I think we tend to replace us I
completely agree with you and the
business interest I always say if
Goldman Sachs is happy about something
regarding China
I'm usually not happy this is what on
another issue on the tax bill this is
what you were quoted in in the
Washington Post is saying about the GOP
tax bill you said if you look at all the
benefits that are flowing to
corporations it was important to be able
to go back and do more for working
families again in reference to the tax
bill otherwise the message is what it's
been for 25 years from both parties that
is when push comes to shove you know we
want your vote but we're not all that
concerned about the working class this
is what Trish Regan said I thought you
were a guy who liked lower taxes lower
taxes enable people to keep more of
their money but now perhaps because it's
beneficial to him politically he's
trying to divide the Republican Party
yeah I don't know what she's referring
to when they say that I am for lower
taxes I think the whole debate began
with this okay we have a corporate tax
rate at 35 our bill the Republican bill
lowered it to 20 I said why don't we
lower it to 21 which is still massive
again we're talking about C corporations
okay we're talking about Apple and
Google these multinationals not talking
about S corporations your everyday small
business mid-sized business I'm talking
about big multinational corporations for
the most part I said instead of lowering
to 20 let's lower it to 21 still a
dramatic cut and let's or let's actually
said 20.9 and let's use that 0.9 to
fully expand the child tax credit for
working families people make 30 40 50 60
thousand a year and my argument was that
point nine was better in the hands of
these workers that have already been
hurt by all these changes but it's over
that I see what you're coming from but
that's over now we have the midterms and
right it's like Republicans have to be
unified on this issue and I can see the
argument that we all get it or y'all
gotta hang together here on this tax
bill it's what we have it's not perfect
the issues not the tactic we didn't get
it yeah the criticism not about the tax
build is what it is and on net it's a
positive the issue is the attitude the
attitude that some people had towards
that child tax credit that oh well
that's you know it's better off in the
hands of these big corporations than it
is in the hands of a working family that
attitude is going to be ongoing and we
cannot continue because working people
in this country have been crushed over
the last 20 years by all these changes
we need to think about that too yeah
that's for sure and and we'll see next
year the full force of the tax bill will
kick in when they have to file their
taxes under this new regime in 2019
Santa rubia before we let you go big
blockbuster story today in the hill what
do you make of this story
the Muller had not disclosed this before
the he was named of course special
counsel well first of all the Bob
Levinson is a Floridian his family's
from Florida I wanted to do everything
possible within the law to get him home
and and and I we've met with the Trump
administration about his case he
unfairly detained his case was forgotten
at the end of the Obama administration
whether they're cutting deals with Iran
this is a man who served our country and
was unjustly kidnapped by the Iranian
Russia this is senator Rubio a Russian
oligarch used 25 million dollars
according multiple sources of his own
money to get this guy out yeah it's so
and so bi right and so I'm on the
Intelligence Committee so I want to be
careful about confirming or denying any
sort of media articles because a lot of
the work that's being done with regard
to this I'm not confirming it like I
said I saw the same article suffice it
to say that he is here's the bottom line
mister models are conducting this
investigation if there is a conflict of
interest at some point and it's born to
be true it would jeopardize the
investigation I'm not prepared to say
that we don't know all the facts I think
we'll see as this thing rolls forward
and as he brings out the you know this
investigation has to end at some point
people will be able to look at who he
went after and who he didn't and then
ask these questions but we should wait
until that moment arrives but on this
particular case you know we have that
article I don't even know quite frankly
how any of that is classified or not at
this point and so I would be I
personally cautious about I'm not trying
to be evasive I don't want to get in
trouble here go beyond where I should
but suffice it to say for purposes of an
investigation
Bob Muller should be able to finish his
work and then we're gonna be able but
and it has to end at some point and
you'll be able to look at it all and say
hey why did you do this or not do that I
think we're gonna learn a lot more about
this in the days to come but we really
appreciate your voice on China and all
these men a tional security issues marco
rubio thank you so much for bearing with
us tonight and thanks for joining thank
you